my exclusive interview with BTS and
you're watching hi friends this is the
daily Deni I am so excited because the
day has come i sat down with the boys of
BTS the global pop group taken over the
world and with their epic AMA
performances days away they are just as
excited as we are we are so excited you
guys are on Entertainment Tonight we
love you guys so so much
we saw how excited you were when you
were here for the Billboard Awards how
excited are you now that you're gonna be
back for the American Music Awards
[Applause]
cannot believe that we have our first
time average u.s. televised debut on
American award American Music Awards so
I mean like it's gonna be I think a new
opportunity to reach out to the new fans
and you know like I'm show them that our
music and performance is something that
he can relate to like even if it's in
Korean them are you guys there's gonna
be so many people at the AMAs is there
anyone in particular you guys are
excited to see I like Selena Gomez I was
something the Gomez yeah okay dad yeah
Dianna Rose Lady gaga gaga the Queen
she's Queen she's so good yeah what was
it like arriving in the US and seeing
all those fans waiting for you at the
airport our faith army love you I mean I
love you that's right yeah who else you
guys want to work with who else are you
dying to collaborate with Jo Guk can I
guess Justin Bieber Yeah right
jvin looked you guys up who doesn't love
Justin Bieber huh no one alright you
told us that your album love yourself
her was part of a new era right so and
you want your fans to learn to love
themselves and learn what true love is
so I'm gonna ask you guys what does true
love mean to you
we always think when we don't have it
like boyfriend or girlfriend we always
say like I'm so lonely I want to I want
a date you know sunlight
but I think I thought the biggest love
we all searching is like the love for
myself so I mean like if you want to
love others I think you should love once
maybe yourself or myself first
now you mentioned you know you want a
boyfriend or girlfriend do you guys have
time to date you're so busy I think
there's a lot of different kinds of love
not just between a boyfriend and
girlfriend but you know though with your
family
lower the people around you I think
that's really important and I think it
worked oh I love the people around you
and love the world I love each other I
think they wouldn't you know be a good
thing for the world and make a better
world
those guys are a blast and we'll
actually have more with BTS on Friday on
ET and here on the daily Denny I got the
guys to answer some of the fan questions
you all sent us so be sure to check back
here Friday for their at responses but
moving on though to mr. Blake Shelton
who has officially been named the
sexiest man alive and no doubt this
comes as no surprise to his girl Gwen
Stefani you see what I did there
Gwen posted this pic with the quote I
guess I've been kissing the hashtag
sexiest man alive all this time but
people I knew that already
still the Internet have a lot of
feelings about the max pic NBA star Evan
Turner tweeted heard my dude Blake
Shelton won People magazine's sexiest
man alive way to hold it down for all
the 7s out there we appreciate you
louis Ratelle tried to make sense of the
choice writing Blake Shelton is sexy if
you like a guy who's always about to
lean in and tell you about hearty
healthy American dog food and finally
dana schwartz tried to settle the
argument she wrote Blake Shelton is at
best the sexiest divorced dad at this
barbecue well way to keep Blake Shelton
humble a spy Internet but here's
something that everyone can agree on
Deadpool 2 is gonna be so dope we've
seen very little of the sequel but the
first teaser dropped today and if you
ever wanted to see Ryan Reynolds dress
as Deadpool dressed as Bob Ross well
then look no further
that's right that's just good
[Laughter]
all right so we literally only got a
taste of the movie but you got to admit
the marketing for this movie is on point
Deadpool 2 is set for release in early
June 2018 that's it for today thank you
guys so much for watching and shout out
to the BTS army had so much fun reading
your guys's tweets Wow more for you guys
tomorrow so be sure to have your
notifications turn on all you got to do
is ring the bell CF
[Music]